a really big show coming up rudy
giuliani excited for that but I wanted
to let you guys know in addition to of
course please do consider joining up at
laterals credit comm slash muck let me
get shows like this four days a week as
opposed to once along with extended
interviews as today with Rudy Giuliani
as you'll see you also get the entire
Blais catalog is wonderful hand etched
mug and it only costs $9 per student
veteran active military I also want to
let you know that you can submit video
questions at louder with credit comm
slash ask we'll be taking those every
Wednesday on Ash Wednesday also if you
have fan videos or submissions some
people do some parodies they're
incredibly insulting and I find them
funny note a lot of credit calm slash
ask and we'll be including them in
future programs as for right now here's
a little bit from this week for non mod
Club members what you missed
[Music]
somebody say Bloomberg okay let's have
Grif read numbers number six pitched
Jeffrey Epstein vehicles number six
carry I feel like I've seen Donald Trump
realize that a lot of people who he may
have gone to cocktail parties with are
no longer his friends seems to me like
you have far less patience for them than
you did oh wow is that a fair assessment
of your evolution since they've been so
nasty yes Lauder with crowder studios
protected exclusively by Walter
[Music]
[Music]
these can be seen
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
amidst the gangs don't snap anymore I
don't
ms-13 and the Crips they're really
phoning it in later make gang snapping
you don't get your face your teardrop
and you have to off somebody but
somebody carrying the mantle and you
know you can snap you can take a wallet
but you can't snap all right we have
former mayor Rudolph Giuliani on the
show today I know many of it we were
promoting it it don't have the real
Giuliani no we actually do any list is
real the only reason we have all these
guests now is because they all are
getting into the podcast space and yeah
now all of a sudden this little crap
show is relevant it is which brings me
to my question of the day Bloomberg
obviously if you watch the debates I
almost didn't want to talk about him
today because he might be done but then
I thought you all want to know why he's
done so what are your thoughts on
Michael Bloomberg what do you think the
chances are for Bloomberg and how do you
think it compares to Donald Trump
they're both billionaires I think that
Bloomberg is far more emblematic of
someone completely out of touch I have
no idea they have so much money they're
different people the rich are different
my half-asian where bill Richman this
year how are you sir hi too many people
were confusing him for Mexican so he
decided he would unbutton it and now
they go crypts but he's wearing yellow
he's getting neutral border black cholo
Gerald Morgan a is here what's the one
who takes one of the day is behringer
Nights Valley Cabernet Sauvignon Oh what
is that so what is that where's that
from it's from Knights Valley is that an
actual place Knight it is right north Oh
it sounds like a book about name okay
audience members here today I'm gonna
pour it over he always comes in and he
doesn't bring he just you know he gets
paid he thinks he gets to show up with
the wine and take it with him you know
he drifted in the contract from now on
in the contract isn't no it's like it's
like to Catch a Predator
we're walks outside and then he gets
mobbed am I free to go
well you can put your pants on and see
what happens and then they're always
surprised every time why are you
surprised
we'll be talking about Bloomberg we'll
be talking about the debates a little
bit
first just um just watch since she's in
phrasing
okay oh wow we get I mean something
something or other your [ __ ] tippy now
that you said in the spirit of full
disclosure and trying to you know maybe
it is a genuine bias I prefer the second
one how'd you two it's yeah put together
I mean the very different standards
these you know here's the one thing I
don't understand I guess the feminist
movement they're sitting there talking
about their vaginas they constantly use
the argument well yo men constantly make
jokes they make jokes and understand
here's the difference we're not
worshipping hard penis we're not telling
you that it's people we're not telling
you that it's braver that's beautiful
it's funny we're making fun of our
penises could you imagine if I just if I
walk up to my wife and with a straight
face said you know my dick is beautiful
and you should respect the penis it's
just there's the fat pride they go
they're fat guys what's Chris Farley the
cover of we've never claimed it there's
a party going on in our like a
marionette device because it's funny you
can make it look like the Eiffel Tower
it's just shapeshifter so versatile
leading the news outside of this since
we got that out of the way I'm sure
Giuliani will be thrilled yes they are
they are they talking about their cooks
yes mayor we appreciate you we rosario
Dawson has now come out of the closet
this is from LGBTQ nation she said
dating Corey Booker challenged
she approached relationships that it did
and she now describes herself as
bisexual and reached for comment Cory
Booker said good for her as he resumed
performing fellatio on the entire
Cincinnati Bengals roster Wow yeah
you've heard of the bearded lady rosario
Dawson is the beard lady she's just a
beard honestly we've talked about this
in the show is anybody surprised is
anybody surprised that rosario Dawson is
now bisexual let me present to you
exhibit a
[Laughter]
what happened
everything just that's all you need to
know like you know when you see people
in a restaurant a couple ooh I think
they're in a fight I see them
interesting like he's gay there is no
doubt that he is gay in case you think
that maybe I don't have enough proof let
me present to you exhibit B why it can't
masculinity be gay at why I know maybe
my gay friends who are incredibly
masculine hyper testosterone we may have
gay rappers if there be one work again
yeah frankly my point is come on
sounds like a statement as it did
advocacy right he was kind of testing
the water a little bit from the heart
really so that sets your cover is there
to Kemah globin levels we wanted his
talk about their latest lab results just
admit that you like so you know last
weekend did you know there was national
hippopotamus right no I missed it yeah a
big just so in honor of the holiday we
actually are introducing a new segment
here we're proud to introduce a
hippopotamus facts just the facts
it's a lot of his facts someone worked
on after hours yeah you know a lot of
facts about hippopotamuses which is
really a sham it's a pandemic don't
people are hippopotamus ignorant it's
worse than the coronavirus you're right
it is it is important that's the death
toll up to it's still not high enough in
comparison to should say high enough
it's not as high as people who are
ignorant of hippopotamus think you want
a hippopotamus for Christmas you don't
know what you're asking for
you really don't know so here's the
eponymous fact for hippopotamuses love
water which is why the greeks named them
the river horse that's where it comes
from
yeah hippos spend up to 16 hours a day
submerged in rivers and lakes to keep
their massive bodies cool under the hot
African Sun
Wow these are things I didn't know
here's another 140 other facts I got
plenty that can go all day and I decide
when this segment stops Oh gotcha
okay Potamus is lifespan is up to a
forty years in the wild and fifty years
in captivity and the last eponymous fact
a baby hippo is referred to as a calf
yeah baby hippo this has been the first
installment of many hippopotamus facts
just the facts
a lot of his facts let it percolate
you're gonna be you're gonna be saying
that you're gonna be like six hours from
now everyone's gonna be like just the
fact like by Menon and Jesse Ventura's
and coastal facts and then he's gonna be
outside of a tower seven with an acne
plunger um in other news Pearl Jam
frontmen you know Eddie Vedder yeah
right yeah which I always forget I
thought Eddie Vedder was a professional
wrestler
that's like Vader it was a guy from Boy
Meets World
Eddie Vetter he told his congressman
that the boss ticket Reform Act is quote
flawed and a lot he actually took some
time I do respect this when celebrities
take time out of their schedule his busy
tour schedule by the way with Pearl Jam
to speak before a congressional
committee on the issue and I think we
have video yeah joining us today to
discuss his problems with the boss
ticket reform act Pearl Jam frontman
Eddie Vetter mr. fetter the floor is
yours
[Music]
[Music]
I yield Mike that's probably wise smart
move it's probably wise he's a poet
in other news poet and rip Levi's and an
Iranian woman said that she's afraid to
return her homeland after loosening her
a job at a Chess Championship and this
comes from the Washington Post pointing
to warnings that if you come back
this is what they wondered they will
arrest you and there were allegations
that she hadn't warned her her job at
all so Wow may I say here as an American
with all due respect what a [ __ ] so I am
um you know that was the official in the
police report written in her home nation
that was was it yeah it's exactly it was
a complaint what what what a [ __ ] but
wait a second hold on a second but I'm
actually getting word right now that Amy
Klobuchar has yep she she has a comeback
oh the point of this is I believe in
transparency I had a physical by the way
it came out well we might all be
surprised if my blood pressure is lower
than mayor Pete's that might really
shock everyone out there
we'll keep you abreast as this unfold
taking a cyanide racial screams of the
moderator even chew just swallowed it
it's like an anaconda unhinged his jaw
will keep you abreast more unfolds Amy
Klobuchar jerk store called so a
teachers union by there's another story
and we'll get more to a Bloomberg and
then Giuliani after this a Teachers
Union lawsuit filed by spokesperson
Randi Weingarten is now claiming that
Betsy DeVos capriciously repealed
protections for student loan borrowers
so the trial actually will be turned
into a made-for-tv film starring Adam
driver so when you see it does make
every woman apparently you know what it
is when you look at that it's it if we
can bring that back up it's the brow
Ridge it's the angle of the nose and
then it's the flat lip but the haircut
is just she gave us a gift yeah it's not
genetic Janice makes th sheep salon
that's easy yeah Vidal Sassoon won't be
knocking me before we get into more
detail has everyone heard by the way
that you know that Bloomberg everyone
knows that the in Burgas is considering
picking Hillary Clinton
are you yeah I love I can tell when
half-asian bells prepare for the show
when you look at these like gee why she
picked Hillary Clinton what's going on
come on all sort of like reading down to
the bottom of the page
yeah David shut up I'm reading hold on
Hillary Clinton as his running mate this
comes from the Daily Mail polling found
a Bloomberg Clinton ticket would be a
formidable force to take on Donald Trump
should be another polling also shows the
chance of president elect Bloomberg
being assassinated at inauguration at
100% oh wow wow yeah you didn't feel it
and there's a plus or minus variation of
0% gotta get so that's the plan for
Democrats Bloomberg Clinton 2020 or as
we call it Rust Belt poison I'm not
gonna get him yeah Bloomberg Clinton
2020 ignoring flyover country since
always
I don't know how out of touch they could
possibly be good yes at the very least
people have been saying that this guy
will restore some dignity in the White
House
oh the tail
[Music]
get some some consultants oh my god
doesn't have enough money for somebody
to help all that is required for him to
avoid that is one person to say no no no
we get that you have more money than God
but listen to someone other than you
this is a bad idea going on with the
black guy from kimmy schmitt and the
dinosaur tail is not going to play well
with anywhere other than these four
people in this off off-broadway
production it's a disaster it's awesome
you will lose Wisconsin and everyone
hates you and your money who's just
Barney Ursula and Godzilla had a baby it
was Barney banged Liza Minnelli
apparently well look I feel more
talented than him so that that's helpful
for me for you as soon as it was
announced is it really so much well I
guess it's news I'm not sure if you came
across this as soon as it was announced
it's little for voting it's just a
picture of Alex Jones hanging himself so
that seems yeah poor guy he didn't do
that swift recovery thoughts in person
yeah finally by the way before we get to
more on Bloomberg Donald Trump took his
limousine for lap of course you know
around the Daytona 500
we didn't need to run that clip I just
felt like this was a big this is of
course a part of a president Trump
strategy you know to reach voters expand
his base and now with some even newer
audiences as seen with his his most
recent visit on his press tour to the
Joe Rogan experience the girag an
experience it's exciting to have you
here man and it's obviously an exciting
time for you
you know presidential campaign is up in
full swing yes it is and frankly it's
about time that you had me out of your
show okay especially after you had
frankly crazy 30 I was just a horrific
super homicidal [ __ ] psychopath well
Joe I thought you endorsed him I thought
Joe Joe I would never call him a
psychopath
maybe he's crazy okay can we all agree
that he's crazy folks he's crazy birdy
it's silly fun okay I wouldn't use that
language but those two words are what
are the misconceptions
okay frankly is that is that better what
are you trying to give me your static
this guy why excuse me
the biggest misconception is that I
tweet all day I frankly Joe okay I'm too
busy to be doing that though would I do
tweet okay Jimmy it's awesome break like
this one NBC anchor Chuck Todd looks
like a failed polygamist cult leader and
I don't care who knows it
polygamy is drugged Chuck Joe that's
what I said [ __ ] that the Chuck now that
is not a bad tweet but I saw a scientist
who was writing I am unfollowing him he
is using his platform irresponsibly a
lot of [ __ ] virtue signals really hey
baby yeah baby okay be a great baby okay
baby you know who you really support is
trouble it's sick he's one step at a
time
actually Jamie do you think you could
pull up a video so Jamie Singapore Jamie
if you could pull up a video that I'm
looking for
yeah okay kitty if you could pull up
this video
oh is that is that Patti a phone
a horse okay Joe got mustard [ __ ] see
where he quit smoking the read marijuana
is obviously a big issue in this country
well you would know Cheech or you Chuck
what do you actually wait I have an idea
okay if this is septic this is something
that's just coming to me
yeah Jimmy what if you okay excuse me
you Joe Rogan's moderate a presidential
debate
I just wanted to convince CBS and NBC
and ABC to go along with some probably
match but I'll put pets at it you'll
just need to probably frankly I would
never ask you this but you'd probably
need to redact your ad or spit of crazy
party I mean he was just a horrific
super homicidal [ __ ] we get it keeps
going back man the power of new media he
can get anyone he wants good for him hey
who's the trivia contest winner from
last week the record winner is shoe
Mandan I don't know that's a weird name
there's no good one yeah who originally
he knew my original nickname was your
nickname it was a key grip Garrett until
we actually all found out that you were
a quarter black yes
came out of the Black Hawk and we were
stunted yeah yeah it wasn't really the
black closet it was a broom closet I
didn't have much room in the old editor
you there because we didn't value your
work but that's change no not anymore
not anymore I appreciate it yes Thank
You Man I appreciate you taking 77 cents
on the white dollar so it is time
actually I don't think well we don't
need a meet do have a meet segment intro
we don't need a meet segment show
because this is actually this week it's
a little bit different cuz it's the POS
intro so let's talk about Mike Bloomberg
again I don't know what you guys think
is it you see the same kind of
billionaires Donald Trump why do people
see Donald Trump as a billionaire who's
of the people a little more in touch and
Mike Bloomberg is someone who is
completely totally out of touch I think
it's because of exactly the kind of
behavior that we've seen from Bloomberg
the less to himself basically trying to
buy his way into an election wars if you
look at Donald Trump he did actually go
through the process he was in there
early on in the primary yeah I mean it
was it was a tough slog and I just think
people didn't know how do you prepare
for Donald Trump in a debate like Ted
Cruz Harbor
right right yeah actually published
unlike Barack Obama and he shows up he's
ready and then Donald Trump just says
your dad killed JFK
and if you just say no he should go he's
flat-footed chef me of course he wasn't
ready for the insinuation that your dad
plotted to murder JFK I don't know it's
just a little bit of a Chauncey Gardiner
effect but it worked for him as opposed
to Bloomberg who's just spending all of
his own money Donald Trump as donors
people wanted Donald Trump to win I
don't know that anyone wants Bloomberg
to win this was his first debate
performance last night and it was
universally panned as a disaster as a
matter of fact for people who missed it
the the whole debate was a disaster he
sounds like the lily tomlin
operator what's the absorption rate do
Ethiopian genetics affected I have no
idea are you an ultra-rapid metabolizer
the point is i get that you want to die
Lester so did I so let's look at all the
reasons that Mike Bloomberg is a piece
of
[Music]
alright I'm gonna bring in my half asian
water bill because he's uncomfortable
and I'm gonna bring you in more against
your will completely you're so quiet
today reason number five is uh I think a
lot of people remember this that the
soda ban a lot of people know big gulps
maybe didn't understand how unpopular
this was in New York City of all places
so in 2012 Bloomberg actually banned
sodas over 16 ounces in all of New York
City I think that you're not gonna see a
lot of pushback here at all I thank
everybody crushed Wow free should do it
he may not have expected to hold another
press conference later that same day
you've expended so much personal
political capital on this everybody else
do what's right to save lives
obesity is just no question about it he
was he banned sodas and then of course
represented the ban was promptly shut
down by a New York Supreme Court judge
though I will say to be fair many people
believe he was bought and paid off by
big Kwik Trip so there's that how did he
think that just a ban of 16 ounces isn't
that a lot when I read big gulps I was
thinking the baking the plan ounces is
the medium-sized yeah yeah I have no
idea not even the big gulp Big Ups like
32 this is like half a goal no big gulp
was like 48 is it really I don't know
super big gulps double big gulps kids
[Laughter]
wait thank you for correcting I'm taking
it incredibly literally when Gerald is
buying his black and milds
and the big gulp has changed over time
on the legal point there's clearly
everyone attacked this on the left the
right because it was either it wasn't
enough it wasn't specific enough how are
you gonna say what the type of drink is
yeah what the specific thing that we're
involved with but then you're actually
contributing to more problems because
now people are just buying both
packs of drinks yelling you know buying
multiple cups so instead of one large
it's good for the environment Z bar and
you end up with what I call the Chris
Pratt effect yes he comes in and it's
very very very in trouble oh I made yet
plastic bottles yeah yeah well if he's
trying to prevent people from drinking
like super sugary drinks one you
shouldn't be doing that let people make
their own decisions but it ban like diet
and sugar-free things as well as iced
tea it can be a health beverage right is
a perfect example of the unintended
consequences in giving all of your
rights over to the government you have
to clear everything to be a
constitutional right like they do in in
Germany I don't think they have the same
constitutional you but they declare
internet or I don't think they do either
so if you declare the right goods and
services that right can be taken away
this is someone who has no concept of
the parameters of government if it may
help people and it won't let's assume
that it may make people healthier it's
not your job to ensure that people don't
overrun by mr. pip boo who drinks mr.
mister by the way I think you tried to
ban Taco Bell different personal reasons
we can't get into there's an NDA here so
reason number four as to why such a
piece of excrement um
let's remember the homeless food ban I
didn't hear about yeah so he actually
banned food donations to the homeless
because the city couldn't quote assess
their salt fat and fiber constant yeah
so no food at all yeah that's better by
the way it's pretty much everything in a
can drive oh my god right you're not
buying prime organic rib eye let me tell
us this in the bag never a Girl Scout
cookies no you're putting in the Jolly
Green Giant green beans if anything now
you just be doing it to spite Bloomberg
yeah it's not like they were trying to
donate the bottom of the muffin I mean
who would do that I I would just give a
little time that's what means just to
piss you off
smelly ass City as America note because
he wants to be President of the United
States and I think it's important to
know that this is someone who probably
won't be president of let's be honest he
won't be President okay yeah if it's
Bloomberg and Hillary Clinton 2020 let's
just call it from 2020 on the scoreboard
let's be honest here but he wants to
push these diet regulations at the
absolute highest levels of government
wind up with a lot less sodium in the
food
we eat is really crucial to our health
and our fitness governments at all
levels must make healthy solutions the
default social option for the things
that we run because of all sorts of
safety reasons we just have a policy of
my understanding of not taking donations
right okay we get it
no one should be allowed salty fatty
food ever except
Oh No
so much you know it's a little bit
gangster good for you oven berg you
affected elitist by the way he also
wants you to know that the face is just
genetic he didn't have shingles it's
good it's good we'll be a dumpster fire
so reason number three that he is a
piece of walking fecal matter I don't
can't be a piece of fecal matter is that
a Jen I don't think you can get grammar
nazi' audio way he can be a piece of
fecal matter certainly he says certainly
when it's very clear it's like when a
fighter knows he's gonna lose and he's
trying to like I am confident that I
will win because you've already lost
you're gonna take a dive so reason
number three this is a good example and
this is also I would like him to run
because talk about the coastal Elise
right this is someone who has he's so
out of touch with Middle America
he doesn't realize that this will come
back to bite him people want to talk
with the NDA's and the sexual harassment
the truth is that Donald Trump has shown
you can turn that into a positive if you
have the right I said they let you fish
of their own volition folks so he did
say this though far worse than the NDA's
or sexual that farmers are effectively
idiots so he claimed in this I think we
have its clip right that anyone could be
taught to anyone anyone could farm but
that tech jobs take quote real gray
matter here you go and we could teach
processes I could teach anybody even
people in this room so no offense
intended to be a farmer you it's a
process see you dig a hole you put a
seed in you put dirt on top add water up
comes the corn Wow that's all that goes
wow that's because you did farming I
knew I'd seen him somewhere Bloomberg
good for him process C Singh yeah yeah
if I ever say anything that stupid
please comedian lee come in it not this
show we'll do it afterwards long list
but speaking like I get it I said Mike
as opposed to Nike because of the French
Canadian or solace
sounds like solace and that's just
because I'm a stupid cane it's a silly
country but process see shows you don't
understand that word right you don't
know what that word is supposed to mean
you don't know what I'm supposed to mean
it's making of things that people
understand please do hit the
notification bell if you're watching on
YouTube hit all notifications because
otherwise you don't get them at all I
guess anymore and subscriptions don't
mean a lot there's also crowd or bits
jewelry does it go and watch some
exclusive content of course mug clubs
will keep the doors open because we're
not monetized but it's not really a
spoiler alert Lee well know that if
you've read a news article in the last
year ever reason number two we have two
more reasons to get you then we have
mayor Rudolph Giuliani um he I don't
know the way to any other way to frames
this but um he wants old he wants old
cancer patients to die yeah accurate I
would explain but here's the thing I'm
on board
Mike now aren't you he held it in the
hole I was saying nothing just so that
would have the impact I intended so let
me tell you all the reasons no I'm
kidding one child policy and no cancer
exactly okay roll him to court tomorrow
no just in the morning so let me explain
that the context of this I'm not this
isn't actually hyperbole at all he wants
to expand government-run health care
right course they all do and he's
praised socialized medicine in Europe we
know that but he has some very
interesting ideas I don't think is any
different than the people who are
pushing for Medicare for all they just
don't usually come out and say it this
way as to how they might cut some health
care costs so we've done is sit here and
say we're station
nobody wants to do that you show up
let's prostate cancer you 95 years old
we should say go and enjoy have a nice
to leave a long life no cure
right oh my gosh you think he doesn't
even consider the fact that you are not
the one who's supposed to decide
I get that logically people are saying
someone's 95 they probably don't have
long to live
here's the thing it doesn't matter if
they want to pay for health care
Bloomberg doesn't get to choose whether
they live or die and by the way this is
what happens in socialized health care
countries a lot of us don't know this
that is very common later in the meeting
he went on to describe how socialized
health care was superior to ours by the
way and he said if you look in Europe we
spend here about 7,000 odd dollars per
person per year on health care in Europe
it's about 3,300 less than half and
their life expectancy is two to three
years greater here's the thing a lot of
you wonder it's a common stat people
cite life expectancy is not related to
health care we have test holiday that
changes the average by like three years
yeah just straight out choose to be
obese Peter can choose to be very fit a
good example that is Texas right yeah I
think Houston is the fattest city I
think in the country no yeah that's what
I believe in depending where you go like
obviously there's a higher concentration
of them at the last Kmart left yeah and
if they're shooting a commercial less
than 60 I think Dallas so I'm not
mistaken it was rated one of our the
city with the most fit people because
you have a lot of athletes here the
thing if you are in Texas you can eat
incredibly healthfully at a very low
price or you can eat nothing but crap
that's a byproduct of freedom that's
also the byproduct of being able to pay
for your own health care you get to
choose when you no longer pay for health
care or when your life is no longer
worth living Bloomberg it doesn't even
occur to him because they believe that
all of the rights belong to them yeah so
when I was talking to a gentleman from
Scandinavia and he was saying you know
oh if you dire why would you what was he
a chef go ahead yes so he was telling me
about him what people don't realize is
that you eliminate the choices once you
move to a centralized system you
naturally drive out of the market any of
the private options and so there become
less and less and less and those that
are available are more and more
expensive so when you have an
a five-year-old who says I would like to
get treatment he may not even have the
option to go pay for it within his own
nation right so a lot of the wealthy and
these Scandinavian nations and other
nations was socialized medicine they
will fly to the United States and get
care because we still have the option to
buy it so what people say is they go
well you know at that point sure the
central government isn't gonna pay for
it but they'll have other options but
once you've implemented the system there
is no market threat heat the private
option is so odd that he picked prostate
cancer and $95 an example so I get 95
you're doing pretty well I have a
grandmother in law who's 96 and she's
doing really well we have people who
live to 110 111 I think oldest person is
112 all the time so prostate cancer is a
very slow-moving cancer it's very
treatable cancer what if that guy is one
of those people who treats the prostate
cancer and drinks a glass of wine every
day to the day he dies and lives to 112
you've just robbed him of 17 17 years
this is very common this is it's not
even a controversial issue in Europe
even the extremes of death panels where
people got really mad when we talked
about death panels
remember the cases of I think was
Charlie guard Alfie Evans yeah they're
both children severe health problems who
wanted to try alternative treatments the
UK government decided that it was time
for them to die and those are extreme
examples let's go to the rule rather
than the exception rationing surgery is
extremely common in places like the UK
elderly blind patients they're currently
forced to wait a year and a half for
simple cataract surgery had a girlfriend
by the way in high school whose dad was
German actually fought for Hitler he
refused to get cataract removed because
the doctor was Jewish true stories about
pissed myself laughing and then felt
really bad and told him he was a racist
they sent him to a second doctor he
wouldn't get it removed because he was
Arabic true oh yes
yes twice it was when I was introduced
to him know like hey here this is this
is epi and he fought for Hitler but he
doesn't believe it and then I find out
he's refusing hard I guess and this is
something people don't Canada where I
was raised like my mom was having to
wait a year and a half for an MRI when
my family moved to Canada in the 90s
there were only 12 in the entire country
Wow and my mom ended up getting one I
think within about seven or eight months
because it's a lot of these social I
systems if you have
you can find a doctor right but the
Supreme Court in Canada shall we versus
Quebec I've talked about this quite a
bit it didn't happen until after I moved
away actually declared it a violation of
Human Rights not civil rights because it
was entirely socialized you were not
allowed to have private insurance at
that point or you couldn't rather pay
cash to a doctor let's say you were
dying you had cancer and you wanted
right hay for alternative treatment or
you just didn't want to wait you weren't
allowed to pay for a doctor there was a
doctor named show.we who decided to
compassionately take care of these
patients right then he was put out of
business because that was illegal the
Supreme Court ruled it a violation of
Human Rights I believe in 2005 to force
patients who are effectively on death
row into the waiting lines of socialized
healthcare if they want to pay for their
own healthcare so now they have what
they call super hospitals or as we know
them the United States hospitals this is
one of the most baffling arguments to me
right when you're trying to solve the
healthcare problem there's two parts to
it one is we know that when you go and
pay cash for services that you pay a
fraction of the price that you have to
pay on insurance right so the solution
is abundantly clear you can go and see
what the solution is every single day
the next thing is why are they
constantly running to pushing everybody
onto a program where the absolute end
result is you don't get to decide about
your health care anymore
you are no longer the person in charge
of what happens for yourself it's about
the ends justifying the means right it's
not about the best care it's not about
it being easy it's about it being
centralized that's then it's our our
it's it's a hundred percent what have
you ever actually heard Bernie Sanders
or Elizabeth Warren say we would have
better care they say oh it might be
cheaper they say it'll be less calm
it'll be less complicated you won't have
to deal with insurance companies despite
the fact that the overwhelming majority
of Americans actually wants you to keep
their insurance plans they always argue
it the right thing to do not that it's
going to be better quality right because
dealing with the government has proven
easier than dealing with insurance
companies right well that's there at all
like Medicare you know are people like
Medicare and Medicaid but you're dealing
with very very small percentage of you
expand it it gets more difficult by the
way pops Crowder is he's usually around
here in the studio he's getting a bicep
reattachment surgery done today he
flexed too hard when it just popped no
reason it was it was actually even
Brennan when they were doing jiu-jitsu
and he snapped his bicep and we fired
him very promptly
Reverend oh that's a good example
there's a window that closes right now
he's going through this we're nearby set
basically scars over you have to get it
done within two weeks yeah and he
thought he was fine that's the scary
thing if you're he just heard like a
twang is it oh I think something's I
think something's wrong and then after
we're looking like is here but is your
arm supposed to look like a like a
window shade or a rolled like when you
have a lip use is a really attractive
skunk and it looks like it's a babe and
it goes by that was his bicep and he
said no I don't think it's supposed to
be that went into a doctor immediately
he gets to go into surrender he's going
to be in there before the cutoff there's
no way that would have happened in
Canada no right man no way whatsoever so
I know you want socialized health care a
lot of you I'm not a fan reason number
one that Michael Bloomberg is in fact a
piece of [ __ ] and I think this is the
obvious one he's really he's just a
billionaire who's literally attempting
to buy an election right notice that
here's something that here's some
numbers that a lot of people don't
necessarily know have you noticed the
charities that have an endorsing
Bloomberg coincidentally he gave them
millions
Wow millions of dollars what about the
Democrats surprisingly endorsing
Bloomberg surely they must believe in
his ideas they like the Liza Minnelli
tracksuit that he wears but it also
doesn't hurt the loom berg that the
three House Democrats supporting and
received eight point nine million
dollars from him in not 2018 midterms
not connected at all no by the way that
that law works like a charm doesn't it
with campaign donation cats jerk did
hard time Craig think giving five grand
to it is running a Senate seat it didn't
even win yeah he's walking around an
ankle bracelet having a blow in his
niece on to make sure that he can go
down the store to get a gallon of milk
let's give an eight point nine million
dollars to people endorsing him in a
national platform and have you seen the
folks there's another thing the folks
endorsing Bloomberg on social media hey
I take that personally I will spend that
under 250 dollars wisely thousand to a
hundred thousand followers on Twitter or
Instagram a hundred and fifty dollars
for an endorsement which begs the
question how much for a million or five
million YouTube subscribers who comes
out at
in snow just DMUs right but here's what
I hope happens I hope he spends tons of
money he will write he's spending tons
of his own money to do all of it's his
own money option do I don't have a
probably I do I write and he is
completely honest about it he is telling
the public he's telegraphing and I'm
trying to buy the election I understand
elections cost a lot of money I just
hope he loses a ton of money in the
process
I don't know if it'll hurt him he's got
so much of it yeah because he's gonna
lose either way there's no way around
this right
but hopefully it cost him a lot I'd hope
it hurts I get a shingle yeah perfectly
good with him support I mean he's gonna
spend three hundred four hundred five
hundred million dollars great boost the
economy everyone will laugh for you we
got more laughs out of it I mean I was
excited to see him in the debate it was
entertaining
so I feel like America is winning with
this and he's gonna lose yeah he will
absolutely listen well it hopefully he's
this money that's being spent on him is
being thrown down the toilet right and
it's not being spent on another Democrat
candidate that he's boosting and
supporting right he's not boosting their
campaign so maybe that's a way it is
really remarkable here where you try to
figure out Brautigan who works for us is
really wonkish I don't know what the
Democrats are doing it's it's like you
have the war and you have the Sanders of
the world the radical left socialists
and I think what's happening is they
realize that oh my gosh actually people
are don't want around yo socialists so I
don't think it's going to work and so
rather than recalibrate you'd think
they'd go with a club which are abide
they're gonna I know we need someone
who's a real centrist so we're going to
go with a corporate billionaire elite in
Bloomberg and Hillary Clinton we're
going to go so far the other way to
guarantee the Midwest is a red wave the
likes of which we've never seen how do
you go from Bernie Sanders yeah to
Bloomberg split the difference folks
give Klobuchar are just a couple extra
minutes for her comebacks I'm sure
she'll do you right vej minute this is
this is I think the big problem to have
with Bloomberg I think is Moe it's most
emblematic because it's just sort of
bumbling Bernie Sanders proactively
blatant just what in disregard for the
Constitution or parameters of
appropriate limited government
I don't think Bloomberg has any
understanding because he's so wealthy
he's such an elitist he's surrounded by
yes many has been for so long he'd
understand that he's not a king that he
shouldn't be in charge of these issues
and by the way let's compare this to
president Donald Trump when people say
well he's a billionaire so he's a
dictator but right really by lowered
and deregulation and allowing that more
people to have guns like allowing more
businesses to open up fewer stringent
regulations you can say whatever you
want but that's not exactly the actions
of an autocratic dictator Bloomberg
thinks he can control what you drink
and by the way 16 ounces that's not a
whole Starbucks when I go to Starbucks
Reserve and I ask them to make me one of
those clover coffee machines is very
rare was on the road now they don't want
to see that comes up like a puck like a
burger patty and they they squeegee it I
really the coffee's terrible but I just
wanted to see how the quarians right I
brought them my thermos they said we
can't use that I said well this it is
too small I says it's it's 10 ounces so
we don't start before 14 I said what
it's to less then Mike Bloomberg wants
to ban in his city you want to put this
man in the office I'm saying that of
course the CSIs Lee I know that none of
you want to put of an office anywhere at
any point and these are and we have to
get to Giuliani a little bit these are
the unintended consequences of big
government it may sound good at this
point Medicare for all let's assume that
the quality of care would actually be
better or Medicaid for all or some kind
of a centralized public option let's
assume it would actually be better it
doesn't matter because long term you
lose your choice and they can decide
what health care is taken away friend
maybe long term people not drinking big
gulps I think we would all agree
lots of sugary sodas not good for you
but if you think hey that will be better
for me so let's have the government step
in it's their job to to keep us safe
it's their job to ensure health guess
what it's their job to take away
whatever they want these are the people
who told us that saturated fat and that
egg yolks were bad that tallow was bad
for McDonald's fries so they started
cooking that with hydrogenated vegetable
oil now that I'm sorry we were wrong
about that sorry to everyone who has
elevated LDL and cancer we were mistaken
but the vegan activists and the USDA
kind of screwed the pooch on this one by
the way you can eat eggs now you I am so
tired of being told that I cannot eat
eggs or bacon and now now it's a good
thing yeah and then you have people go
so far now they're the carnivore diet
now the USDA is going the other way we
don't know what is the food pyramid can
anyone tell me what the appropriate food
pyramid is whatever Mike Bloomberg says
I believe the opposite let's just go
with that whenever
you allow the government to step into
the realm of no longer rights what are
rights they're enshrined in the
Constitution freedom of speech freedom
of self-preservation freedom from
unwarranted search and seizure but goods
and services like drinks like health
care like yeah even drinking water being
filtered and piped to your tap when you
allow the government to have complete
control over goods and services they can
take them away and you end up with 12
ounce soft drinks which we all know
we're not satisfying and some might
argue more importantly death panels this
has been this week's what if he
[Music]
all right I need to go find a Hillary
Clinton's diazepam pen stab myself
because I have Rudy Guiliani coming up
out of this anything better behave I'm a
fan I get it
hey Jimmy could you bring up the clip of
the turtle humping timberland have you
sit in jail you have to see this what
yeah it's not the one it's better look
it's got a loafer it's a Timberland boot
the Turtles just go to chow chow
why why me he's getting over that what
Joe look you see I love it
that's my favorite jack
[Music]
at least what you do online is your
business protect your business with
expressvpn with this bit he was learning
how to cook a cat because he's a part
Asian so little bit of racism but that's
okay
hey if you watch the show you probably
spend a lot of time online you probably
have cut the cord and which is funny too
we talked about cord cutters that's
already out of touch because no one
there's no people don't use cords
anymore for cable so even the people
talking about cord cutters are out of
touch cord it's anyway if you're on this
show you probably spend a lot of time
online and if you're like me you're an
idiot who didn't realize that everything
you do is tracked I thought I went in
private mode and no one could see me
looking up pictures of tests holiday for
a Photoshop mind you it was incredibly
embarrassing with expressvpn and right
now by the way if you go to expressvpn
dot-com slash Crowder you'll get an
extra three months of the service for
free another interesting fact you
probably know what a VPN is right it
protects your online data your IP
address
lahter you probably know it is but they
didn't a lot of you may not know
expressvpn actually hasn't had a data
breach that they they omitted to tell
their customers about just run a google
search on that and you'll see I can't
say who Brand X is but it's kind of a
big deal so expressvpn coms flash
Crowder sign up it's easy to use and
you'll be protected and they have the
balls to sponsor this show we use it we
like it give it a whirl expressvpn duck
comes closer
[Music]
let's call the Baker
and that is the sound of the weekend a
lot of Fundy I'm your host Jared Lundy
video studio as always we have
half-italian Jared Church of Widow pass
it to me Mario stalking them stock Jalen
need zero for what's though one of the
day
yeah the one of the days German alright
I'm very glad to have our next guest and
I say this I always have to say it but I
don't mean it but this is one of the
it's very rare that we get to interview
where I get to interview you're not
everyone someone who was Person of the
Year
personal right here and rightfully
Person of the Year not like that Hitler
who rigs the voting
yeah long time ago he had his inside
scoop time and well I'll bring him on he
was actually pretty a pretty important
in my formative years politically
because I went to we started a family
tradition of going to New York City for
Thanksgiving every year the very first
year we went was after 9/11 and we went
down to Ground Zero and so I learned all
about our next guest you can follow him
on the Twitter at Rudy Giuliani his web
site I want to make sure I get this
right as Rudy Giuliani x.com Julia and
Nick's ICS calm and the podcast now that
has going on is common sense highly
recommend you check that out this is a
former mayor of New York City US
Attorney for the Southern District of
New York and then associate United
States Attorney General I believe I had
that all right he's also the current
turning to the president mr. Giuliani
thank you for being here sir
it's a pleasure to be with you more
importantly fantastic cameo on Seinfeld
yeah I didn't list that yeah that was
that that was the morning after I got
elected mayor and I had no sleep really
Oh sleep that night yeah yeah and it's
funny I just didn't hit halfway you know
sleepwalking but it was it I've gotten
more attention for that and some of my
Saturday Night Live appearances
particularly dressing up as an Italian
grandmother
right yeah someone just made someone
just made fun of me for that and I said
that it was a with an anti Italian
bigotry or something or other
transgender appropriation but you know
come on I just get a little confused
about my agenda what just one day this
is back in the Bob Hope could dress up
as a lady interesting the troops
nobody's money but now it's just now
you're appropriating apparently a
cross-gender culture is a culture that
we can appropriate so I apologize that
you had to go through that will have a
PTSD counselor emailing you soon there's
there's so much going on but obviously
we were just talking about Mike
Bloomberg running for president and I
hate to ask you about another guy but
there's obviously a lot at play there a
dynamic you being mayor and then him
being mayor he's he's taking some fire
right now for for what they're saying a
racially charged comments he made
regarding the stop and frisk policy I
won't ask you first how do you feel
about him trying to walk this back now
even though it was an effective tool in
the war I don't I don't buy into the
racially charged or I know Mike probably
on the person I'm one of the people that
knows the two men better than any person
knows the two of them separately right
played golf with both of them mm-hmm
known known the president for 30 years
no Michael for 20 who's a better golfer
Oh Trump by a lot yeah well you have to
say that other truck truck truck I don't
have to say Trump is close to scratch
he's about seven now maybe six though I
don't even say younger man he is a
scratch guy Trump plays golf with my son
all the time my son's a professional it
was a professional he retired okay and
he he plays two you know two plus so I I
gotta be honest with you mr. Giuliani I
don't know anything about that I'm
Canadian we only follow hockey sounds
like you guys have great golfers we
don't really have great much but we do
have great hockey players maple syrup
there's some nice things a prime
minister not a big fan
yeah I don't buy the racially-charged
thing either it seems like a smear but I
do notice the difference with him unlike
what you're saying now he's sort of
trying to walk it back in the media well
that that and that offends me greatly
because and it offends me that he hasn't
made a distinction that I think he's
required to make right he talks about
being apologizing his program was found
to be unconstitutional and he says he
inherited his program from me and ill
Bratton and Howard safer and Bernie
Kerik we were the people who developed
it but there's a distinction the program
that I ran was held to be constitutional
by none other than Eric Holder and Janet
Reno right I defended the program myself
in early 2001 at the Justice Department
I explained the rationale for it I
explained Terry versus the United States
and that we were doing it properly and I
proved to them that we were by seven
eight years later he wasn't just
searching a hundred thousand people he
was searching six hundred thousand
people and he had a success rate of only
five percent right which means 95
percent of the people that he was
searching were theoretically innocent
and that's a lot for people who don't
know he sure he was stopping and
frisking it was people could argue far
more initially invasive it was faster to
the punch and he it was less successful
so there is a delineation there in
practice and it's not my program no I
mean if my program was very carefully
calibrated done really well by an expert
police department by three great
commissioners we kept a scrupulous
records the Justice Department wanted to
sue us the Eastern District of New York
wanted to sue us on a asked for a
meeting with the then Attorney General
Janet Reno and our deputy Eric Holder
and I myself argued the case and I spent
two hours and I showed them that there
was not a single constitutional question
with it
that the statistics were all perfectly
normal
yes we were searching mostly
african-american males but in exact
percentage in which they were reported
as the people who committed the crimes
in other words a race wasn't determining
who we searched our complainants were
determining who we searched
right and it was basically black people
who were turning in other black people
so I get a complaint from a black woman
that a black male hit her in the face
what do I go do look for an Asian yeah
me I I don't know I have no idea you
could but I would imagine no I mean so I
explained to Eric and I explained to
Jana how stupid it was right
how stupid their case was now I would
have done the same thing for them if
they had asked me to represent them but
because I'm a great lawyer I would have
had a difficulty getting around that
five percent success rate ours was
somewhere around thirty five percent
maybe forty or fifty but the most
important thing is ours was totally
geared toward perfect use of the
constant statistics secondly we kept
scrupulous of the Terry foundation Thea
half delay now neither Michael Michael
wasn't a lawyer so he saw it more as how
do I get guns out of the community you
got to see it as how do I do it legally
and then collaterally how do I get guns
out of the community right
he flipped it around and that's how he
went up to six hundred thousand because
for keeping guns out of the community it
was damn effective if you search
everybody every day in every community
they ain't gonna be no guns right this
is also gonna be no Constitution problem
it seems to me that we should be
starting off with a jumping off point of
well let's get rid of crime from the
community and so if your arc starts that
way it might be a little different you
have to you have to get rid of crime but
you also have to understand that we do
make a trade-off we make a trade-off for
certain rights that we're not going to
violate even if it might be more
effective in reducing crime I mean if if
we didn't have the Fifth Amendment and
we were required everybody to tell us
everything about themselves
we probably solve more crimes right well
you have a Fifth Amendment so people can
protect themselves I have an trade-offs
in a civilized society yeah I have an
aunt who you can maybe speak with as a
lawyer as a constitutional lawyer who
doesn't understand the Fifth Amendment
because she feels a need to tell me
everything all the time including the
regularity of her bowel movements I
always say you know what talk with Rudy
he can set you straight
what do you think the chances are before
we move on to star the Ukraine and
impeachment obviously what do you think
the chances are for someone like
Bloomberg since you know both him and
President Trump of winning if he adds
Hillary to the ticket also someone who
spent a short amount of time in your
home state before she ran but you know
she's seen as a New Yorker now well I
think that Mike would have a very hard
time beating the president of just on
the merits I mean they both have a
record the president has an expanding
record of her form he's done things that
most of the presidents haven't done we
haven't had an economic boom like this
maybe maybe Reagan maybe Kennedy
although I think this is bigger and
stronger yeah we're a country that's
relatively at peace he solved a lot of
foreign policy problems or put a lot of
them in the right trajectory and after
it after taking over from a terrible
president who had us you know in
subjugation to China and by the way Joe
Biden was the guy negotiating with China
well if there's a connection with the
fact that he caved in with him all the
time and they were partners with his son
you know in his private equity fund the
term negotiate very loosely if it's a
synonym for bend over sure yeah yeah
okay then they they send him they send
him to China because the Chinese went up
into the islands and threatened Japan he
came back and there were more Chinese
threatening more Japanese and the kid
got a billion dollars from China right
now I don't say there's a connection but
I can't say there wasn't a connection
because nobody's ever investigated it
well that brings me to my next question
here with obviously they've been trying
to oust this president for for three
years they said the day he became
president they were gonna find a way to
get him out of there did you ever
imagine that that it would be your
mission to collect evidence as that I
think we're just talking about before
the break I don't ever want to speak out
of turn and I know legally we can get in
hot water so you told me we can talk
about but collecting evidence on the by
no it rains
yeah no I never I never thought of that
in a million years and I didn't go
looking for Biden and and we didn't
neither the president nor I I mean they
say we went to gather dirt on Biden
that's a bunch of democratic garbage
we didn't go gather dirt on by that's
what they were doing on Trump so they
used that language right I was given on
a silver platter by Ukrainians who were
frustrated because they were being
obstructed by the FBI and the USM
see they had this information for a year
and a half and the US Embassy would not
give them visas to come to the United
States the FBI told them to forget about
it
they had information about how a phony
black ledger was created in order to say
that manna fort got 12 million dollars
worth of bribes they held the press
conference and leaked it and the hole
with the DNC and the whole purpose of it
was to take Trump out when they didn't
take Trump out they went ahead and began
the criminal investigation a metaphor
that was the thing that struck talked
about we have a plan to stop him we're
going to leak information about a
made-up crime right and then we have a
then we have an insurance policy should
he get elected we're gonna start
impeaching it we're gonna start turning
these things into long-term crimes
canasa now just operating that was
operating in Ukraine it was operating
with the whole situation with
Papadopoulos with the phony FISA warrant
it's all part of the same thing it began
at least I can take it back to about
January of 2016 in the White House when
they when they had a NSC meeting
national security council meeting
staffers the staffers they are told
three or four Ukrainian prosecutors
three of whom will testify under oath
mhm you gather dirt on Trump the Trump
campaign and Paul Manafort one of them
one of them possibly is the same
whistleblower the phony whistleblower
who came forward for Adam Schiff three
years later right now it's this guy if
this guy was out there trying to take
him out in January 2016 how credible is
his garbage you know a couple weeks ago
right this guy spent the last three or
four years trying to take out Donald
Trump and what he did what he did if
he's the guy in the White House who did
that he committed the crime they were
investigating Trump for he asked foreign
officials to directly interfere in our
election right and nobody's investigated
any other Obama people what every every
Trump person gets investigated for you
know not paying a parking ticket on time
and then the guy forgets and they put
him in jail for perjury well you are
notorious for unpaid parking tickets so
will Wolfe
that we don't want everyone to know your
parking ticket history there mister
Julie this to play devil's advocate here
my questions what is the FBI say in to
go back to in sort of blocking these
Ukrainian whistleblowers from entering
the United States what is their art no
nobody's questioned the FBI so these
these Ukrainian whistleblowers three or
four of them hired a lawyer about a
month or two before they came to me and
they went to the Justice Department and
they presented their case and they
directly told them they had evidence of
Ukrainian collusion in the election and
they had evidence of bribery concerning
Joseph Biden and they would they would
never ask back well why don't we get
another beanie could they Skype in with
their tests could they Skype in their
testimony you're like why did everything
they sent it that's why that's why
that's why the left that's why the left
tries to beat up John Solomon they sent
a lot of the information of John Solomon
and he published it in the hill and now
and now you know they've made him into
some kind of monster this information
was given to me now they say it was
Russian it was Russian
counterintelligence in other words the
Russians got Joe Biden to threaten the
president of the Ukraine with not
getting or not getting a loan guarantee
unless he fired the prosecutor any guys
to say this on sailor they got yeah well
there was a guy who saw the Russian
behind they're pushing the strings and
tell him to do it yeah right then it was
the Russians then it was the Russians
who got hunter Biden to take about eight
million dollars from them in laundered
money a hunter didn't get paid like most
people get paid he got paid circuitous
route it went from Ukraine to Latvia
made made made out to be alone then it
went from Latvia to Cyprus another loan
right and then it was distributed to all
of the board members and in the case of
hunter and his partner they forgot to
put the amounts in right and one of the
Ukrainian prosecutor what to get the
amounts he was told that the US Embassy
had told them the amounts how to be
stricken so that sounds like these
payments that sounds like a Spirit
Airlines flight path last time they're
going hey we're not gonna make it see
you're going to be landing in cedar
Rapids Iowa you know you know what
that's called that's called a stone-cold
money-laundering case right which you or
I would be in jail already
yes nobody's even investigated nobody's
even investigated there's no show job
son of the vice president and I wanna
and nobody's ever asked and nobody's
ever asked with all that money that went
to Hunter was it really a bribe to Joe
right so he would intervene at the right
time to save her crooked five billion
dollar company which he did right he
saved barista which was a crooked five
billion dollar company and he got one of
the biggest crooks in Ukraine to be able
to return because got the case dismissed
on him and what is the son of the vice
president doing making millions from one
of the biggest crooks in Ukraine when
he's our point man they're trying to
straighten out corruption imagine how
that one would get up to give a speech
and he would say now all you Ukrainians
have to stop being corrupt and they
would yell back hey how about we start
with your son Joe Rice yeah how about we
start with with the no-show job son
right it was a drug addict you're subtle
about corruption you phony yeah you
first mr. Biden we do have to go and I
want to go to a web extended here it's
Rudy Giuliani XCOM that the the podcast
is common sense for those who are not
medical members we're gonna continue
hearing web excited final question
before we go to that though if you want
to ask you as a layman okay and I see
this and I see Joe Biden and all of us
see this footage of him saying this on
camera for people who thinks it's a
conspiracy just go back to episodes
we've run this clip ad nauseam how is
that not an admission how is that not
admissible but then so why understand
why there's conflict Americans when he
said it he said it that's it's exactly
the same thing they said Trump said and
every newspaper in the world the next
day printed bribe writes exactly what
they what they falsely said Trump said -
szalinski he said - Solinsky you don't
get your money unless you investigate by
Biden census - the president poroshenko
you don't get your money unless you fire
the prosecutor same thing for one it's a
bribe for the other it's oh my god poor
Joe well who did it doing
poor job right poor little Joe right now
is a may not make it across the street
be very well may not he's doing
commercials for hub around these days
that's why it's hurting everything all
right we will be right back after this
for those who are not among club members
the podcast is common sense with former
Mayor Rudy Giuliani really happened
[Music]
[Music]
Bungie black rifle coffee
[Music]
[Applause]
can they see me yeah yeah yeah they can
see you well see that's the problem with
the fact that we have five-pound bags
here at the office and we use them all
this is all I have left
um black rifle coffee calm slash credit
go there you get 20% off your first
order there veteran owned company
support veteran causes but their coffee
is better and I do like it when there
are companies that support good causes
especially in the coffee industry
because you've got Starbucks and you've
got all these companies who support
horrible causes but I would not include
a sponsor on the show if their coffee
was crappier than Starbucks it's
definitively better try it for yourself
black rifle coffee calm slash Crowder I
love this in the espresso machine
they're a vintage roast and the gunship
roast is my favorite in the coffee
machine but you know you do you
[Music]
[Music]
that's me that's called me every doesn't
in my neck fat do not act as gills oh
it's not functional what is this
what am i a bearded dragon what is this
no I find out what this is recently from
a genetic test I don't talk about my
health so much anyone but called
ehlers-danlos my body hasn't produced
collagen so let's see g5 yeah all the
stretchy and put my foot behind my head
Ripley's and I deal with crippling pain
but I don't talk about it because Lena
Dunham claims she has it oh I don't know
but that's the least of her problems um
anyone else out there who's ever had to
deal with us or has a genetic testing
it's it's amazing what they can see in
your genetics when I did this testing I
said I don't want to know if I'll get
Parkinson's or Ito tell me do not tell
me I know what enough do you want to
know the day that you died
I've been onstage I know it's most days
but we're talking in the future I don't
know I don't want to know Rudy Guiliani
by the way a whole was there another 20
minutes in a little extended thing we
talked about cigars we talked broken
windows theory I was surprised because
I've heard that he can be a little bit
cranky and he was just a joy to have you
loosened up I hope to have him back
again soon and then next week we have
some big shows coming up a lot of people
asking are we going to be doing the
debates not until it narrows down a
little bit and then it's going to be
busy going into 2016 we're going to be
finishing or covering all of the
finishing primary debates with the
Democrats and then of course the general
and we'll probably have well it could be
a very short night on election night
that's true or it could be very long
I believe let's go around it was a 9
hour stream so I'm looking forward to
Donald Trump winning but I'm not looking
forward to having to cover a long night
of the stream because yeah you know the
Young Turks melting down it's only so
funny for so long it's pretty long yeah
we're 7 by the time I get to 8 that's
true please there are no longer pores
it's just sweat it's just an amoeba all
right so let me close this up for you I
got really dry my mouth is dry I'd like
to take a second to talk about about a
few things here three
things three concepts that I think are
nearly always misinterpreted which is
really which is really sad because um
these three things they're inextricably
linked and arguably these are some of
the most important concepts to
understand and by which to live and
we've always talked about this in the
show where I hate when things that
actually matter are turned into a bumper
sticker slogan because people want to
sell books and that's why I haven't sold
any books I'll write two books in my
lifetime so this is all for free I could
put this in a self-help book and maybe
it'll help you maybe it won't but I
don't you get this for free so three
different concepts fear courage in a
more practical sense that further what
is willingness I don't say what's
courage and it's this abstract no it's
willingness it's the willingness to do
something even though you're afraid and
then finally discernment these are very
important and a lot of people don't have
a grasp of them not saying that I do but
if I've had to learn somewhat and
managing 15 people and running a
business and having to do a lot of
things that I don't want to do so let's
start with this I'll start with fear
fear is often vilified right it's that
fear is the enemy of the good it's
paralyzing there's there's nothing to
fear but fear itself which it sounds
good in a high light really it means
absolutely nothing I don't know what
that means nothing to fear but fear
itself so you are fearing something
you're fearing the concept of fear which
is non-existent it's stupid I get the
people like how it sounds and Oprah uses
it for a book club once you put yourself
on the cover of the magazine every
single month surprise it doesn't mean
anything here's the truth fear is fine
fear is natural fear is logical fear is
healthy fear keeps you alive now like
many things that are powerful and useful
if mismanaged or given in a an
inappropriate amount of sway over your
decisions fear can be crippling see fear
is it is and it should be by the way a
variable that you use that you include
in making an informed decision you do
not let fear dictate your decisions let
me give you an example
the Virginia gun rally that happened
remember was declared a state of
emergency a lot of people don't know we
were planning on going there we were
doing work we were going to do a reverse
change my mind with Schuyler Turton
right there
devil's advocate change my mind it was
the first time we were going into it and
we had some intel behind the scenes
before was declared an emergency that it
was going to be a little bit of a hairy
situation particularly for me I won't
get into exactly how we were able to
procure this information we have a
brilliant researcher reg who scares me
thank god he's on our side but it was it
was brought to our attention that it was
probably not a good idea to go and then
of course it was declared in emergency
and what happened was when I was brought
to my attention I was really tired that
week and we had something that we had
done that week oh we didn't I think
we've done that change my mind or we did
the change coming right after that he's
on the road and I was exhausted right
and so I was planning on doing the
Virginia gun rally but I was really
tired and when they sat me down my team
here and they said hey listen we have
some new info here that we don't think
this is very safe what do you want to do
I said here's the truth I don't I never
want to do these I don't want to go to
Virginia gun rally and I don't want to
have to dress up in Skyler turd and garb
and be around a bunch of people who hate
me there's nothing Pleasant about that
there's nothing appealing about it I
don't want to do it I'm exhausted it
sounds terrible but if you tell me that
I should do it I'll do it I said so you
guys tell me right now I'm in no
position to be making an accurate
judgment because I'm afraid to do it I'm
too tired to do it I don't want to do it
if you tell me to do it I'll do it
and the reason I tell you the story is
is not at all tip to boast or to beat my
own drum I tell you that to hopefully
help you understand that by nature even
though you often see me publicly and and
you know I'm considered maybe a little
bit bold as the kids might say I'm
naturally a very fearful person I always
have been it's it's a huge struggle but
I keep it in check as best I can with
two other very important variables and
that's willingness and discernment I had
to be willing to do something that was
uncomfortable and I had to be able to
discern whether I was making a decision
based out of fear so you've heard the
phrase exhaustion makes cowards of us
all I've quoted that a lot and not
because it's just a sound but I think
it's it
actually is insightful it actually helps
it provide you with information and also
actionable information
I've heard it attributed to both General
Patton and Vince Lombardi so if someone
knows the true origin please tell me do
you know where that comes from I have no
idea I also have seen it attributed to
hens Oh Gracie so I didn't sound like a
Patton quote but if you know let me know
but the quote is exhaustion makes
cowards of us all I think that's the
exact quote you it it's absolutely true
and the person who ignores that truth is
a fool the tough guy who acts like he
always has it under control the guy
who's you know this false sense of
machismo and nothing scares me he's a
liar that person is a liar either to
those around him or to himself take your
pick
but in knowing that fear and exhaustion
will turn me into a coward and by the
way through high school through all my
herbal early life having been dominated
by fear I have decided I made a decision
I remember when I made this decision as
an adult that I won't let fear dictate
my decisions I can surpass my fears
through a premeditated spirit of
willingness I assume and I won't ever
want to do this I assume that I'll be
tired
I assume that I'll be afraid and so I
tell myself and my team here whose
judgment I trust that I will be willing
to do whatever it takes regardless you
can line the devil himself up and if
they say go for it I'll tuck my chin in
March and that's not a statement it's a
statement on the team of people around
me because I do have to truck it is a
trust fall constantly where I know I
can't look at something objectively and
I know that this is easier said than
done
but the truth is and I think a lot of
people miss this you can conditioned
willingness courage what do we want to
call it you can condition yourself to
act in spite of fear as opposed to
because of it how it's like anything
else by putting yourself in very
uncomfortable fearful situations every
day baby steps a little bit of progress
toward your goals and let's say though
let's say that all of you you've been
following the showing we talk about this
quite a bit the strenuous Slice
strenuous lysa strenuous Lysa's it's a
super strain of right of lice because of
antibiotics
that's you now they have yeah they have
superlice boys but let's say that you've
already conquered that let's say that
that you know you have a spirit of
willingness regardless of fear okay
that's the first step well then we find
ourselves all men women too but right
now I'm speaking to a lot of men out
there because I know men are often
afraid of talking about their fear
because they think that it makes them
weak it doesn't I don't believe in
taking pride in weakness but I also
don't believe in being afraid to talk
with other men about you being afraid
that's not a weakness so now we find
ourselves at one of the original
problems I was mentioning earlier and
that fear is a valuable tool sometimes
fear is telling you that this is a bad
decision the oven the stove is hot so
how do you know when you're supposed to
plow through fear as opposed to when you
should listen to fear and maybe back off
and that comes down to the third
variable I'm talking about you the third
principle discernment and I know there
are a lot of people who've talked about
paths to this I've heard it referred to
as in an Enlightenment I don't know the
hell that means you can you can be
enlightened on a given issue or a given
topic but this idea of total
enlightenment as an Enlightenment as a
generality is it's it's a psychological
gavel a [ __ ] it does it doesn't it
doesn't maybe he says maybe I'm just
stupid I think it's [ __ ]
maybe it's just me when people go out
and say you know once you are a piece of
yourself you will achieve total
enlightenment I go you don't know what
you're talking about
it doesn't help me that didn't help
anybody just makes you sound
self-important so I don't want to talk
about enlightenment but I do want to
talk specifically about discernment
let's use that as an example but some
people might refer to this enlightenment
side trail sorry I wasted your time
blame Buddhists so I'm going to tell you
the only way that I know to achieve
discernment in my life the good news is
it'll work for everyone it's a way
anyone can use of course prayer
meditation living a good truthful life
is important not your truth but a
truthful and honest life but I'll assume
you're doing that why because no one who
refuses to do those things can have
discernment
it's it's not possible so I you
shouldn't be watching this but let's
assume that you're doing that you're a
decent person of good moral fiber many
people however who already do that all
of those things right can definitely
still struggle with discernment so I'll
soon you're doing it okay
it comes down to wise counsel it comes
down to surrounding yourself with good
people honest people people who love you
people who you love and you trust to
tell you the truth regardless of comfort
level so with the Virginia rally for an
example it turned out to not be that bad
we thought it was going to be worse we
had to make an executive decision
so with Virginia all that I knew at that
time was I was exhausted I didn't want
to go when I heard some of the intel you
can bet your ass that I was scared hey
you might get shot there gave me a
little bit of a fright you could say it
was spooky
someone get the jack-o'-lanterns out
because I was a it was a frightful time
but I knew that I couldn't allow that
fear to make the decision for me all I
could do in that instance was be willing
to accept the council the discernment of
others here regardless of how it made me
feel and everyone needs that everyone
needs someone who will shoot them
straight and set them on the right path
a straight an arrow regardless of
comfort level you know what not only
someone let me let me take it a step
further not someone because I don't want
you to just think of someone your life
but all of the people in your life in
your close circle of friends and in
chosen family you can't choose your dad
or your mama's but your wife your
husband all of your close circle the
people you trust they shouldn't be in
your circle unless they meet this
criteria so you might question you do
you have that run through a list of your
best friends of your family members who
is it do you have a wife you're the best
friend you have a colleague who let's
say you were in a situation where you
were compromised beyond recognition and
incapable of objectively making a
decision paralyzed by fear who do you
have in your life who you trust to tell
you in that instance all right go here
do that period and you would salute in
March out I want to take a moment here
and I want you to think about it who is
that in your life who are they who could
it maybe be because that's the only way
that I know how to live with fear and
not be dominated by it you need fear a
willingness to live with it and an
understanding of one to respect it which
wire's discernment and that can only be
achieved as far as I know if weather
solutions let me know through honest
living and the power of your closest
loved ones Association the power of
association in your confidence and I'll
tell you what if you do this if you
implement it and if you if maybe you
haven't you've kicked the can down the
road I want you this week to think of
that person recognize that person tell
them that you recognize them as that
person appreciate them and then make
everyone else in your circle of friends
that person where they shouldn't be in
your close circle of friends they you
can still be friendly with them but you
shouldn't have them in your small group
you shouldn't be using them to lean on
when discussing relationship advice or
life-altering decisions you should make
every person in your life one of those
people and you know what when you're
down on the scorecards bleeding confused
terrified and you're hearing a voice
that you trust with your life telling
you what to do and you know that you
have the willingness to do it so you do
it period
it is liberating because you'll never
have to ask what if when lose or draw if
you understand and you learn to master
living with fear a spirit of willingness
and the wisdom of discernment you will
be able to accept the results and live
with it in peace so helped me hopefully
it helps you I'll see you next week
[Music]